how's it going guys today we're going to
be doing a little speed run of drawing a
triangle with opengl from scratch here
so i'm just going to launch a terminal
and we're going to dive right into it
first of all i'm going to change
directory into where i keep my source
files and i'm going to make a directory
called i'm just going to call it try
and we find now let's go into try and we
are going to be using a few
quick little prerequisites here that
you'll need to have
ready to go we're going to be using glad
as the extension loader for c
plus plus and i believe i just used gl
version 3.3
and downloaded it downloads it as a zip
we're also going to be using glfw i have
that installed
through my repo so it's like sudo
zipper install live
glw3.dab or something like that
so you'll just want to install that and
of course we're going to be using cmake
as our build
system to make our make file and if you
need any help with
opengl there's always the reference
pages so i think that's pretty much
everything as far as sources go
so we're going to get that set up we do
need to get the glad
built into our source file here so we're
just going to make a few things we're
going to
we're going to make a little cmag file
so you make
lists.txt
and then we need that glad.c file now i
have that in my download so i'm just
going to copy it over
so i'm going to copy
[Applause]
of course you can do this through file
explorer i'm going to copy into my
current directory with that dot at the
end
boom okay so now we're mostly ready to
go there's just one more thing i want to
mention
real quick i'll open another one of
these
and that is uh that i moved
the header from glad and
to my user file i'll just show you
so it's like i'm from my root directory
go into user
include and then i have glad
and then there's this dot h so this is
available to all my projects all the
time at the point of moving it in there
and you have to do like
a pseudo force copy whatever i'm not
going to explain all that but just so
you know that's where i'm getting the
header from it doesn't like install you
have to move it there manually so
a big fyi all right so let's get into it
what do we want to make first our main
or our c make that's all we got to do is
make both of those we'll do
our main first because that's like the
potatoes of this bad boy i'm going to
use
y go in insert mode and we're going to
go include
glad glad dot h
then we're going to go include
[Music]
glfw glw3 dot h
and then go hint main
i'm probably just going to do this all
in one go and let's go ahead and type up
our main where we go glf w
knit first of all to get that
initialized and glw
window star i'm just going to call it w
and i'm going to just jump right into
glw
create window and then we got to give it
some dimensions we're just going to make
it 600 by 600 we're going to call it
this and these other two options can't
be
null one of them is for like flip
monitor and the other one's for shared
and we don't care so we're just null
and then we want to go geo fw
make context current and
the current context is going to be that
window and
there's nothing else super important
here other than we need to go
glad load
gl loader and that's just
basically con i'm not sure how to
explain this exactly outside my head but
basically it makes it so that
gl can see the screen and operate its
functions onto it
through this glad extension loader all
right
in here we're going to need another set
of parentheses
or glad
load rock and then over here when you
glw
get proc address i know some weird
somewhere syntax but you have to deal
with clad in order for it to work
and then we're all done getting that all
set up so the next thing we need to do
is make some points for this triangle we
want to draw we'll just make a float
called t or it's going to be an array of
floats
it's going to be 9 but we'll just leave
it blank because it'll figure that out
by the constructor here
so we need our points we're going to go
let's see we want
one kind of the bottom left so we'll go
negative
0.5 on the x and
negative 0.5 on y then a zero
and then the next point is going to be
let's see we want to be
up up a little bit but zero
on the x point five on the y zero
on the z and then the next one we want
to be at the bottom right
so it's going to be over 0.5 on the x
negative 0.5 on the y
and just 0 on z once again and that
should do it so
that's going to be a float array with 9
things in it and we need to
be sure we close that with semicolon
otherwise it's going to complain and now
we just want to go ahead and start
putting that right into opengl
and i'm going to make this a little
bigger i should have done this sooner
probably
okay so to get this into opengl first of
all we need
an unsigned int so we're going to be
human
32 which is called v it's going to be a
vao we only need a single one so
we're doing a really simple way here and
then we're going to go gl
chin buffers one buffer and
pass in that v so it can assign its id
so we can access it and then we go
gl bind buffer
and it's the one we just created then
we're gonna go ahead and push the data
with buffer
data and we need to tell it what kind of
this bind buffer also needs gl
array buffer kind of buffer because
there are other kinds of buffers
and for the buffer data also needs to be
kind array
upper and then we need to tell it all
about the data
and uh there's a little hack you can use
here we go size of
our array there which will give us the
size and bytes of the entire array
and then we also but that's not a that's
not what we want exactly
we actually want nine we want how many
elements but to do this
there's no easy function but you can use
this little formula here
size of t times size t divide by
size of the first element in t
and that should return the proper size
and then the next thing we want
is we want a pointer to the first
element which we can do
with that syntax there and then next up
here i think we want uh
gl static draw just need some of that
and that's it for the buffer data
now we just need to set up that vertex
so we go gl
vertex trib
pointer and
uh this is the one that always slips my
mind a little bit so i'm going to be a
little slow and type this one as i
crunch it out let's see oh it's the
first one so it's zero it's three
elements per
point gl float you know what type
and gl false whether it's normalized or
not
i believe that's what it is and then
here we need
the size of each piece of data so
they're all floats so size of float
and last but not least is where this
vertex
piece of data start starts which is
right at the beginning so it's void
star zero and uh
i don't want to explain that too much
but basically all it means is we're
starting at the beginning of this data
sometimes you can have more parts of
data in here like you'll have colors and
normals and stuff and that's where this
would change
uh if you have more but we only have one
so it's just that's all and then we need
to go
enable vertex
a trib
array i believe that's right and it's a
it's
zero which correlates with that number
that's highlighted right there
all right and there we go we got it all
buffered there now we can go into our
while loop
and we're going to keep in our wild
while the window
should be open while glw
window should close
we gotta pass it our windows so it knows
what we're talking about because it's
geo
connect multiple windows and we just
need to do our thing here
we do need to do a clear of our color
buff a bit
bit that's just to wipe the screen every
draw
yeah i don't think it needs further
explanation then we just need to draw
jail draw arrays and
it's already bound and set because it's
only one so
uh oh yeah this is gl triangles
uh comma and that's zero and three
uh-oh now i've encountered the bug where
i've locked up them this happens all the
time with them
yeah okay project name needs to be
capitalized got it
so we'll make we have one problem with
the include
g l f w slash gl okay we missed an h
there
okay uh
we need enable vertex a trib array so we
just need the word vertex in there
enable vertex drive array
and cannot find lgl
so i was right the first time this is
capitalize
and it built and it draws
so it draws down there that's not where
we wanted it
oh we did we didn't do gl viewport so
it's uh viewport is something default
so that's probably why it's doing that
so what we need to do is go
before we go into this main loop
somewhere we need to go
gl viewport
whatever the size of our window was 600
by 600
so crash that rebuild it
i don't like it oh we need to say where
it starts starts zero starts at zero
okay
[Music]
looks exactly so this right here is the
stride
and it is the size of a float
times three so the stride is the size of
three
floats at a time so that should do it
yeah there we go
all right and we are done we've drawn a
triangle we've suffered through the pain
of them
we've got this all done there's our
final code
there's our final c make
[Music]
[Music]
foreign